[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record when we talk about
whatever we want joe really wants to
talk about snowboarding
i wanted to show you guys my footage
from the insta360 because i was
snowboarding
and um i was going really really fast
and it was really really fun
what is an insta 360 360 cam yeah it's a
360
camera cool you already did they figured
it out already
huh they figured it out already what is
it stop me i don't get it figure it out
what is it and a freaking 360 what
company
insta nope we don't know what company we
don't know what it is don't you know
that
i thought the company wasn't 360.
is it i don't know well he has a
different camera than i googled
is it a 360 cam yeah it is that's really
sick i thought it was gopro
no i have a goalkeeper he has a gopro
360. i have the gopro
is that the nine it's called a gopro mac
max which one is it
he has instant three second one the red
one this one oh it looks like a gopro
yeah it does actually i'll show you a
photo one second can we but
yeah okay so i've been snowboard
deprived
right for the past uh i found my lift
ticket in my pocket
the last time we went as a jk trip photo
time
and then continue that thing looks sick
looks like a camera
yeah the last time we went snowboarding
and it was one time it was three years
ago it was a jk big bear trip
remember that that was the last time i
went [ __ ] yeah and before that
it was like three to four years yeah
because remember we used to go
like like every season me and bart
like we would drive up an hour to appear
how much has a uh
season pass i don't i never had a season
pass but i did the deals
like are you good can you shred the
powder
now i can okay yeah are you good mark
i'm okay
i think it's relative jumps in like you
yeah you ride a little bit
they do jumps i know you guys do jumps i
thought you just casually go down the
whole thing no
i mean i do jumps and rails but i have
friends that do backflips and stuff they
go down
five times the mountain while i'm still
trying to make my way down
wow i can't i can't yeah i wouldn't be
there i'd be inside
you drinking hot cocoa that's literally
what i'm like i don't do the hot cocoa
but i'm like is there a bar there
they do have beers there you can put rum
and hot cocoa oh no
but it's hot you don't like hot rum
sounds good right
not really okay my bad never had a hot
time so this year well 2020 was the year
where i'm like oh you know what i'm
gonna do all the things that like
i wanted to do outdoorsy it's 20 21 for
people this isn't a late upload
yeah yeah no no but for 2020 it was like
it kind of worked out with the whole
lockdown right because it's like
oh [ __ ] you know i did like skating i
did like surfing i did like all these
activities
why did i like go away from them you
know and in snowboarding it's been like
so long and we used to have so much fun
doing that all the time and the deals
back then were crazy like
it was like night boarding was like 20
bucks what's night boarding so
after i'm so sick so like um after like
4 00 p.m to like nine or something
right if you go dressed dresses toward
the end
it's like cheaper but it hurts more it
does
yeah the snow the snow quality sucks oh
wow oh really
that's why it's cheaper it's it's
slushier and then so it gets
the snow who wants to be there yeah
during noon um it gets melted
so it gets slushy all up until like six
or seven
then it re-freezes so now you're like
pretty much snowboarding on an ice rink
and then sometimes that's when the
blizzards start to come back so that's
when you get hit in the face and the
eyes as you're going down really fast
this is how i feel about laser tag
because if you go in the middle of the
day it's you versus kids you're gonna
[ __ ] win
yeah you go at night time oh some of the
teenagers recommend some of the some of
the
lonely adults other lonely adults then
you're gonna get more wrecked
yeah yeah but okay if you learned in
southern california
you you're learning in the shittiest
conditions
of snow because it's man-made snow and
it's like
melted and all this stuff right about
big bear is that man-made
yeah most of it is man-made whoa unless
it actually rains and snows up there
right which is
rare in l.a and even if it does you know
our winners are like in the daytime it's
70 degrees
and it melts right so how do they cover
the whole town with
man-made snow like so most of it is like
real snow so big bear is much better
than mountain high because they actually
get their own snow
uh but then they still have to put a
fresh layer of snow if they don't get a
on the mountain so the town's covered in
like old snow that's like frozen and
[ __ ] and it's just
so the town when the town is snowed
that's real snow but on the slopes
they have to put new ones and then they
have snow machines because people are
[ __ ] with it too so they have to keep
it going or it gets icy and just all
these things yeah but that's why if you
go to mountain high
it's usually you go there and there's
literally no snow anywhere
and then there's snow only on the slopes
big bear there's generally snow in the
town already
yeah so it's like it doesn't fully melt
because it's cold enough to where it's
not like
here in the valley or whatever what's
snowboard culture like like what's like
the downtime in snowboard culture
summer no no but like when you guys are
on the slopes and you're done for the
day what happens afterwards
i think most people just go eat okay or
like
sleep do at home maybe i don't know
those places there's nothing to do there
so you just leave you drink probably
drink in a cabin go power party
that sounds good if you're cool you're
saying joe's not cool
i don't drink i can't do the drive just
up the mountain itself i get so carsick
oh really yeah oh because it turns yeah
that's all that's way too tourney
i always try to be the one who drives oh
could you get carsick too so if you
drive is better
no i just don't trust other people
driving oh well it's so scary dude it's
the scariest [ __ ]
ride of your life sometimes yeah but
then like whenever we go on trips with
bart and he like talks to us
he doesn't look in the mirror he drives
onto oncoming traffic
and he's like you know what i mean
because he turns around he's making eye
contact with you and then it's like hong
kong
he's like what's wrong with those people
like i just shut my trap i'm like i'm
not talking
about i don't care if you're trying to
make conversation i was like panicking
so much
so like so i was like yo let me drive
the traffic so i drove like the whole
rest of our retreat he's a good driver
i've never been in the car with him when
he crashed
so i've been in the car many times we
know he's not a good driver we don't say
he avoids it yeah i'm good at avoiding
crashes
well not really you create the crash
that you avoid
scare like screaming and that's what
avoids the crash
exactly it's a team sport i do you use
autopilot she always used to say about
how like like you know how like
you're leaving a parking lot and there's
cars coming borrow away to the last
second and then go
oh my god like what the [ __ ] no and then
until i've been in the car and i live
with them
and that's why every single time you
wait for the car to get
right there then you cut them off and
then anytime he has to make a turn
in any situation he's always on the curb
always that's why i got a truck no
that's just
he just wants to test out the wheels
yeah well anyways uh
this winter i was like this winter i'ma
[ __ ] go
and like do as much [ __ ] snowboarding
as i ever can possible right
and then um actually we were supposed to
do set off the season together
and that's when bart got the [ __ ]
ronas that day
yeah i was supposed to go that today we
went riding we were on top of the slope
like oh [ __ ] bart got [ __ ] rhoda dude
and we're all like no so we got tested
after that
but that was a crazy kickoff because
that's when we started brainstorming of
like oh wait we can
go other places and my friends like we
should go back to my hometown
we have in a vermont new jersey all that
i mean uh new hampshire
there's like a ski resort every 10
minutes
not even exaggerating like if you see
the map i showed bart a screenshot of it
right within an out one hour drive there
was like
20 different ski resorts that you can
hop around to
so i was like all right this [ __ ]
winner let's do it because suck at all
of them well you have to get good first
you have to ride at least it doesn't
hurt the father i feel it doesn't yeah
yeah and that's all we did during this
winter it was the
[ __ ] dopest [ __ ] ever i still have
never done any of that like
you went snowboarding with us no no
never when we had the big bear
that was before my time that was the
other girlfriend probably no no
it wasn't me i could have sworn three
years ago no you weren't there and david
fell down the stairs
no what yeah we had it but no no no
so yes i was at that trip but that first
day
casey and i weren't there oh we showed
up late in the first day we went to ryan
like sort of argue with those other
girlfriends you were at the truth you
just didn't go
no it was a joke but i really thought
you meant the the other
trip that you guys did right before i
started when we filmed
yeah why were you late why are you so
late
uh i think it was isaac related he had
school or something something like that
yeah but that that was a lot of people's
first time writing
yeah i didn't experience that one damn i
know but
that was that was three years ago though
that's just crazy how much time has
passed guys
when you said david sucks i'm like i
remember that yeah i was like
you could have sworn
do you guys get adrenaline doing things
like that because you did snowboarding
and stuff right
yeah i don't know that gives me
adrenaline because i suck
um frustration
i don't know what really anxiety
adrenaline shooting guns makes me give
me adrenaline isn't it
me too i think in being in areas why i
might need to shoot a gun it gets me
okay that's pretty good just by going to
a gas station in weird sketchy spots
because when i um do extreme sports
right i'm so excited that i can't go to
sleep
and thank goodness this video is brought
to us
and thank goodness this video is brought
to you by feels because
feels is a super premium cbd company
and they hook me up with some awesome
oils and things like that
because i really get like my heart
pumping and like going like crazy when i
ride and do all this fun stuff right
that i actually have like
a little bit of trouble sleeping have a
little bit of insomnia in my system
and i'm still thinking about it like i
obsess over things right if i mountain
bike or if i snowboard at the end of the
day
i'm watching youtube videos and
continuing and chasing that feeling that
i just went through
and then um you know i won't sleep till
like three a.m sometimes because i'm
just watching these videos
but with feels i have now like a wind
down routine
where i like take a few little drops and
i go i feel that
instead of continuing this high in
excitement
i decided why don't i just figure out a
way to kind of chill out and recharge
and in the morning i can watch more of
this stuff and continue so i'm not like
sleeping in and ruining my whole day so
this has been
a part of my nighttime routine now for
like about a year
and it's pretty sick because i can
integrate this pretty seamlessly into my
life
and it's not it's not harmful like it
to me it's like a good little balancer
so what is feels feels is premium cbd
delivered directly to your doorstep
and it naturally helps reduce stress as
joe mentioned anxiety
pain and sleeplessness and if you're new
to cbd
fields offers a free cbd hotline to help
guide you
through your personal experience and
feels works naturally to help you feel
better
there's no high no hangover or addiction
so if you're looking to get
[ __ ] up and make regretful choices
this isn't it
join the fields community to get fields
delivered to your door every single
month you'll save money on every order
and you can pause or cancel at any time
which is awesome
so become a member and get fifty percent
off your first order become a member and
get fifty percent off your first order
thank you to fields
thank you very much what are your guys's
advantage
i get adrenaline watching football but
right now my team literally just lost in
the playoffs like literally like 30
minutes ago
yeah i covered myself in losses today oh
no
are you gonna take this off you just no
i'll leave it off
did you hear about how that has an
effect on
human like like depression and things
like that like when your team
loses and like the the real
psychological
your identity to it it's like uh it's uh
it's wired into like like old school
tribe mentality right like if you got
taken over
you feel the depression of like oh my
[ __ ] village got attacked
that's okay like primitively
like attacks into a primal thing in your
brain yeah that's why they're saying
like if you
win you right and burn [ __ ] down because
you're just like on that high
like i just [ __ ] pillaged this
village or like the lakers just won
yeah that's also probably why everyone
has to press as a clippers fan probably
how can you be a fan of something that's
just repeated that's just
self-destructive so are they more manly
for watching sports or
more primitive i don't know if there's a
distinction between the two
i mean there's a dif there's a
difference a primitive what do you mean
versus manly i'm just saying in terms of
like i don't have anything i get
obsessive over like that
neither do i i'm not you don't have a
sports team i mean i like sports but
like mma
yeah like for me i think if i was a
fighter then yeah if i get if it's a
sport i'm
attached to a fighter it never really
goes past the knight
like even with anderson silva he's like
my hero and that one time when he kicked
chris weidman and his shin broke yeah i
remember being at the bar going
what the [ __ ] and then driving home like
oh [ __ ] that's crazy his career is over
but the next day i don't remember like
waking up
well also someone gets knocked out
you're still a fan of the sport so much
that
even if the knocker your guy it's still
a sick knockout it sucks but you're like
damn this is tight
you know yeah it's like activating the
collective conscious so it's not really
like a manly or
manless or thing or whatever it's more
like activating something that
um mob mentality like the mob
can feel a loss and like together they
feel
sad or they feel like strength and but
that
makes them destructive i feel like
that's the way it is with politics
almost
true i see it as the same thing as
[ __ ] team sports it's the same thing
it's like it's kind of like your family
like if you're if you're a lakers fan
then
anyone that's a liquor fan you meet at a
bar you're like
dude you're my brother now you know
especially if you get a couple drinks in
there it's like
we are family man it's one of the best
things about being a sports fan too
if you're like an out and about sports
fan like you will just talk to random
people about sports like everyone feels
cool to just talk about it so when you
win or you lose it's like you experience
those highs and lows together
and the opposite too like if you hear
someone trash talking your team like
what the [ __ ] you saying
this fight it's fight time start
fighting i have so many friends from
boston to like don't ever wear lakers
jersey here please
i'm like oh [ __ ] yeah they fire [ __ ]
serious though they'll fight you they're
like
what you brought up real statistic that
my team sucks
dude dude the year the lakers one i was
at a bar we walked outside
and i was just last year no no no last
year no no this was like the last
the last time kobe won the championship
i walked outside of a bar
and i was just talking about the game i
i mentioned
the name celtics and these two trolls
walked up on me and they're like
what'd you say those are fighting words
right now and i was like well i mean i
didn't say anything i was just like
sorry like whatever you like the celtics
no no no just by bringing them because
they mentioned celtics in l.a
yeah but it's it's so weird because like
the lakers just won so like you had
nothing to be upset about but
the fact that i mentioned the losing
team the opposing team which is i mean
obviously lakers and celtics have a very
storied history but it's like fun and
obviously these guys were
drunk as well or something probably say
about the celtics oh my [ __ ] man people
take it too seriously out here that is
pretty crazy but i mean i hear that all
the time though
yeah what's their uh mascot uh irishman
the irishman
yeah see you talking about my leprechaun
yeah wait they're not claiming him
though no they're like don't talk about
the leopard
yeah don't don't even try don't even
mention
professor snipes you know dude it rains
a little bit there's some sun out like
they see the rainbow they're like are
you serious bro
these are fighting objects once you get
outside
that's kind of crazy i don't know if
i've ever been for something so
hard that i fought like it's kind of
like apple people or like whatever it's
fun to pretend like you're an apple
person or whatever right well in europe
they got those
soccer games and they shut up rumbling
that [ __ ] is
crazy well go to other countries they
throw bombs at the other team
oh yeah they think they kill the soccer
players yeah they [ __ ] literally they
assassinate
soccer players for missing a goal or
something needs to be
filmed it's [ __ ] nuts and televised
that is why
television why would you like you
wouldn't you wouldn't be down for like a
real life hunger games no
no yeah why why why wouldn't i be down
for it murder yeah
live tv yeah it's a little excessive i
think what part of the murder
part well i don't like watching murder
videos personally that's just me
that's just me what if they cut away
right before the murder happened like
the movie oh
like an ad yeah yeah that'd be good
because you know what happened you just
heard the gunshot no it's real life [ __ ]
that i don't want to witness it was if
you were like
i could see it hey we're gonna broadcast
this and
whatever country you guys are fighting
at you put up your best fighter
we'll do this i thought it's called war
but we only have one
on one that'll be tight that's pretty
sick yeah and you have to watch it
yeah like the beginning of uh troy you
know they sent out brad pitt and that
super tall
dude they should just make countries do
that which is one
that's [ __ ] up you'd rather have
entire [ __ ] like thousands of eight
people rather have so many more people
seriously just not thinking about all
the other people
no no because that's going to happen i
mean that's what they're doing in the
olympics already like for example i
think russia or something they
they were doing pretty much no it's a
draft no
way people are you have to sign up for
the draft yourself
but other countries might not draft wait
what are the stakes you never know what
the stakes are
in this life or like yeah and there's
people that volunteer to be a patriot
right
so you get that group from all the
countries and so instead of having wars
when there's
tens of thousands of people that die
it's just one on one yeah and if they
did it for like say live
prisoners right and they said if you win
this one person that wins out the 100
people that are
a thing and they'll all die that one
person gets set free
100 people with time immediately for the
chance to be set free
were there already prisoners 30 in life
in jail another 30 in jail
oh yeah if i was in jail in life i could
get a chance to come back
you're crazy well only one but he earned
it though
he earned it like spartacus well was
that death race
it was a movie like i don't remember no
i'd just rather just watch it as
entertainment in like fantasy world
movie land and not in real life
well that's probably more gory in
fantasy movies you see that one movie
that they blew that little kid's head
off in
asia no what she was like this isn't
real i'm gonna take this [ __ ] off and
then her head exploded off
what movie you're watching what it was
like my hunger games that sounds
familiar
battle royale yeah that one was crazy
that's a crazy movie battle royale real
videos they don't look like that
yeah real videos don't look as [ __ ] up
as the hollywood ones because they got
sound design
and like all that stuff yeah i don't
know i
like the idea but do i like it for a
society
maybe i do i see i didn't see it going
that way with the way that you were
talking about it
yeah you didn't set it up that way i had
to put some thought to it and i said
yes okay i agree knowing joe i saw it
coming
yeah it like it's like when drugs are
illegal there's more crime or when
prostitution is legal there's more um
crime there's more underground stuff
there's more pimples
there's more diseases but pretty much
every country where it's legal
it's are you saying we should have the
purge oh yeah i never knew you thought
so creatively
because then i have to be a part of it
yeah [ __ ] that not if you're
rich i don't know
[Music]
uh